We're back with Kym Whitley and Finesse Mitchell!
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
I am seriously having the best time.
Finesse, it's your story.
It's my story.
Okay, listen up.
Now, to all my parents out there.
Now, it's been a little rough for a while now,
but you're doing a great job, and you know it,
give yourselves a pat on the back.
(applause)
No matter how you feel inside, you're doing a good job.
This pandemic isn't easy.
But a new study finds that many parents actually do
kind of feel like they are superheroes when it comes to
their kids.
The Good News Network reports, a poll of 2000 parents found
the majority said that they discovered superhuman reflexes
within two months of having their kids.
That's me.
Like the crazy baby catching reflex.
I've done that.
Or having the ability to have eyes in the back of your head.
We've all done that.
You know when your child is sick just by looking at them,
we all have that power.
Kym, Drew, what superhuman powers do you think you guys have
attained since having a baby?
It's like sleep deprivation with a cape.
Let me tell you something.
The nights I stay up and still go to work the next day,
it was unbelievable.
Your eyes are burning, but you power through.
I have super hearing.
I heard the baby, I'm telling you,
way down the hallway, I just heard (coos lightly)
I was like, "Oh my God, he needs me!"
There's so many things you didn't know as a parent.
I adopted my son at four days old and I was like,
"Oh my God, I didn't have him.
I'm not gonna have all the things that mothers have"
I got every last bit of it, yes.
(applause)
Wanna know what my superpower is?
What is it, Finesse, 'cause you're a great dad?
I have a three year old, I have a seven year old,
both girls.
My superpower is restraint.
(Ross and Kym laugh)
That is my superpower.
How so?
I was thinking about it.
Just so that when they argue with each other or they try to
pull those stunts because they don't want to go to bed.
That whole, "Elle, Eva, let's, you know, it's time.
We're not gonna play these games" You know what I mean?
But see, I wasn't raised that way because my mom used to be
like, "Get in the bed, I'ma count, 10, nine, eight"
You know as a kid, you wait 'til they get to about three,
and then you take off running because you know
what comes at one.
But if I start counting with these new age kids,
they finish counting for me.
(laughter)
They start clapping like, "We did it!
We got all the way to one"
And I'm like, "You're not playing the game right"
But they don't even understand or get it.
Patience, so your super power is patience.
What a good dad you are.
And girl dad, that's so fun.
Two girl club.
Yes, two girls, two girls.
I love it.
Am I gonna have kids?
I don't know if I'm gonna have kids.
We had our, Wellington's nephews over
and I got, they're like 10 or 30, I don't know.
(Kym and Finesse laugh)
I don't know how old they are.
They're somewhere between 10 and 25.
And I was like, "Hello, how are you?"
I don't know how to be around kids necessarily.
I don't know, I don't have, but I think that's a super power
you get when you have kids, suddenly you just.
Like my mom, her superpower.
She had like a thermometer in her hand.
I'd always be like, "do I have a fever?"
And she'd just touch you and be like, "No.
Yes, no" There's those things as a parent, you get.
I do not have those things right now.
Could happen, Rossy.
It could.
Well, if it happens, it'll be on purpose.
We're not gonna have any mistakes, that's for sure.
(everyone laughs)
Will be no surprise babies here.
Gross.
All right.
(laughing continues)
All right, well, you know, let me move on.
I'm moving on.
All right, you know, life is full of milestones,
weddings, having babies, baby showers,
and now there's another celebration people are having,
a divorce party.
Yeah, okay.
The blog PureWow reports, people are throwing
their newly divorced pals a little soiree to celebrate
a fresh start.
So if you've got a friend who could use a pump up party,
here are some tips to throw a divorce party for yourself.
Keep it intimate, they say, keep it upbeat.
They say, get it catered, nobody wants to cook.
Buy a big cake and bring some thoughtful gifts.
I say, get a pinata made that looks like your ex.
(all laugh)
Now that's a party.
That is a party.
Here's what I was just thinking.
Sometimes that can get a little messy only because
the people, your friends and your ex-wife's friends,
they're the same friends a lot of times.
So you're inviting half of those friends
to your divorce party.
Which means they're telling the other friends,
which means it gets back to the person
that's being divorced.
And she told two friends, and they told two friends.
And in divorce, both sides aren't usually as happy,
equally happy, somebody either still wants to get
back together or somebody's, you know,
hanging on to hope, so that I don't know,
somebody that's just like, "I'm getting divorced, finally!"
That just makes things worse,
especially when kids are involved.
I think you should invite your friends
from college, you know what I mean?
The friends you've had for a million years.
They gotta be the original friends that told you
not to get married in the first place.
Yeah.
(Ross laughs)
Friends you had to let go because you got married.
That's it, Finesse.
(upbeat music)